it's very good you know that's why we
have him on the show every Wednesday
Steve Crowder steven crowder with louder
with Crowder and now he's in Ann Arbor
Michigan for some reason or other how
are you by Skype of course cuz you're
all over the world and we and we catch
you where we can let's just begin
briefly with a Canadian story but we're
but we're selling to the Chinese now the
reason we have this relationship now
with the Chinese and I have enormous
problems with it because at some point
they're gonna turn around and want
something but we're trading with the
Chinese principally though when it comes
to oil because President Barack Obama
peace be upon him won't play ball he
won't do business with Canada because he
has this anti oil anti pipeline fetish
what have you got to say for your
country sir well I can say something for
both countries being both Canadian
American firstly listen you know I
actually knew the person who broke the
Keystone pipeline
story initially it was someone named
Kathy Shadle you actually may have had
her on this network right to the website
five feet of fury she's she's okay she's
owned every Wednesday and she was on
earlier this show oh this is really an
expertise as far as the others the
Keystone issue but here's the first
people want to break in town into China
and the United States into Canada here's
what it comes down to either the United
States is open for business or it's not
the policies from Barack Obama have been
bad for business across the board
whether that's you're a small business
owner building textiles or you're in the
oil industry and it's so much easier to
vilify Big Oil listen Barack Obama did
is vilified big oil and that was his
excuse for really shutting this down not
shutting it down before you from United
States perspective not buying from
Canada and the only people that hurts
are Americans and of course the people
who work in the oil industry in Canada
not people who benefit of course we
don't necessarily one benefiting I don't
know how else to say this in a way that
don't sound racist but the Chinese know
when I said the Chinese I don't mean
Chinese people because God bless em I
love them they make great dumplings I
mean obviously the the economic
superpower we're talking about in a
country that is very unstable
yeah I'm looking it's post-communist
it's a form of fascism now and I mean I
don't think I'm being hysterical when I
use that word but you have a very
powerful militarized state nationalism
and and also so foreign expansion that I
I hope they do change but I have my
doubts about it and I don't think this
whole idea that listen you know China's
gonna be the next superpower and you
know some people who say this I don't
think they can because of the
fundamentally godless country and you
can have people who are building an
American electronic sending over this
kind of technology but they'll never be
able to use without people in that lower
working class finally saying wait a
second we build these things we send
them over to the land of really really
cool stuff and we're ruled over by jerks
why don't we get to live in a way that
is decent in a new world and sooner or
later that has to happen it has to
change so that's when I don't
necessarily buy into the China hype that
you see on all these jokes then it
referred to as business networks in both
Canada United States mm-hmm
well maybe Batman can solve the problem
which is a rather clumsy segue into this
terrible shooting that took place
sociopaths and murderers will always be
with us
people labor over this what can we do
what what can we do frankly we could
there's nothing we can do a free open
society will always contain some very
ugly people who will want to cause harm
but thank God there aren't many of them
but the exploitation of this and within
moments we had that great philosopher
the guy who was on Seinfeld the guy
there that little fat guy what's his
name anyway he he was tweeting yes whose
career has gone so well since that show
he was tweeting why we have to have gun
control all of these actors coming
forward to say we need more gun control
I don't think we need gun control we
need psychopath control right
yeah well George Costanza Jason
Alexander
why don't you implement gun control with
your bodyguards that's the thing as
these people live in an elitist world
they don't understand what goes on and
means to America they're completely out
of touch they see it as flyover country
why are we allowed guns why is this
considered so important the United
States because it's literally written
into our Constitution is literally
written in there it's one of the most
important things it's right up there
with freedom of religion and freedom of
speech and of course you have people
like Michael Moore of people and Holly
you don't have to brain cells to rub
together politicizing the issue before
the bodies are even cold that's what
really bothers me what bothers me even
more is the media being complicit in
this listeners if you guys want to talk
about having guns or not having guns
that's fine any day of the week but they
bring it up as a key issue now because
it's a hot topic and they think they can
make a few bucks and advertising dollars
but really bothers me even more is I
hear this all the time Michael in the
media this senseless act of violence a
senseless act of violence the headline
everywhere firstly violence isn't
inherently bad the act of killing
somebody Michael is inherently immoral I
can kill somebody to steal his wallet or
I can kill somebody to protect a woman
from being raped
so when you say senseless act of
violence you've assumed that violence is
bad and that what you say senseless does
anybody look up the definition of
senseless in the dictionaries senseless
means either one of two things
foolish and stupid or meaningless this
wasn't a stupid Act
it wasn't a meaningless that this is not
a senseless act of violence this was a
premeditated calculated act of evil now
when you get into that territory you
have to say calculated act of evil the
media is not comfortable that because
that breaks down the parameters of moral
optimism that they set up for themselves
nowadays you have to acknowledge at some
point that there are people out there
who aren't evil regardless of gun laws
when you start off with senseless act of
violence for your lines are the people
who are watching your networks
you're lying the people who are reading
your papers or you're just a dummy
mm-hmm you know I of all things last
night one of my couple of my kids are
watching was it jump 21 Jump Street or
something which is a a very unfunny
movie full of foul language it's but
endless gunplay endless gunplay I find
it deeply ironic that the very
celebrities who say we must have more
gun control make movies glorifying gun
use and glorifying criminals and drawing
a line which is very blur between
between good and evil
it's it's a strange world but probably
stranger under Barack Obama again peace
be upon him than it was before
hey always a pleasure having you on the
show my friend you look lovely in pink
or maybe at some and I don't argue about
it you take care of yourself thank you
thank you sir